although tesla has been around for
nearly a decade becoming one of the
biggest consumer car manufacturers in
the process a lot of you might be
shocked to know that that is not what
the company's main goal is see from the
get-go the goal of the company is making
the entire automobile industry
electronic and sure high-end sports cars
and low-end family cars are great there
is one department that the company has
had its eyes on for a while and that is
heavy vehicles or as we all call them
semi-trucks and it makes sense too since
the industry is colossal earning 726
billion dollars in revenue according to
the american trucking association in
2015 alone while employing a massive 3.5
million drivers so when the company
revealed their first ever prototype semi
truck all fresh and clean looking with
the latest and greatest of the industry
it caused a bit of division among people
a lot of them considering it a fad and a
way of tesla to destabilize the already
great trucking industry while others
claim the thing would be a failure
however the truth is much different from
either of those things because the tesla
semi is going to single-handedly
revolutionize the industry and in this
video we'll tell you exactly why keep
watching to find out more about the
truck what we know about it what it
means for the industry and where the
company is headed in general the
industry let's start with where the
trucking industry stands at the moment
that is as a centi billion dollar
industry on an annual basis that makes
it one of the biggest markets in the
world and tesla's decision to make it
their target first before say public
transport makes perfect sense let's take
a look at some statistics in the
industry you see although the industry
is almost a gold mine for anyone willing
to innovate for years it has remained
stagnant and empty with new methods
having been disappointingly slow in
arriving just take a look at the costs
according to most sources entry-level
semis cost upwards of one hundred
thousand dollars the annual diesel costs
can run up another seventy thousand
dollars with total operating costs
coming in at around one hundred eighty
thousand dollars per year and well tesla
has the perfect answer for that tesla
stations you see although the design and
the tech and everything are important
parts of the semi and we will talk about
those in a bit it is the operating costs
and the efficiencies that make the semi
so damn genius first there's fuel the
biggest cost in the daily shipping
business according to elon musk the
company estimates that charging at
tesla's power stations will cost about
seven cents per kilowatt hour
translating to a fuel savings of between
one hundred thousand dollars and two
hundred thousand dollars each year and
those costs will be maintained and
signed off on by tesla so buying into
the semi is like buying into an
exclusive cheap fuel club a genius move
regenerative braking and then there are
brake costs the biggest long-term
maintenance ones see because of the
immense weight of large trucks they
carry a lot of momentum and that wears
down the brakes quickly add to that the
fact that the brakes already have to be
massive and as a result expensive and
you have a huge cost every few months
and tesla solution not only fixes that
but also fixes the fuel saving issue and
that is regenerative braking this method
which turns the motor into a turbine so
that it uses the motion of the wheel to
generate electricity instead of the
other way around can actually recover
the energy you put into a vehicle as a
result that allows the battery to
recover about 98 percent of the truck's
kinetic energy so all that energy that
would otherwise go to waste will be
recovered with no problem and as a
result this has caused the company to
claim that the semi's brake system can
last for its lifetime even more absurdly
musk claims that these savings mean a
tesla semi will pay for itself in about
24 months efficient design the
efficiency extends to other parts of the
car as well not just stopping with the
fuel and brakes since the stylish and
almost futuristic design is not just for
show you see the engineers at tesla have
realized that if they remove the grilles
at the front of a car which their
electric architecture allows them to
they can also reduce the drag on the car
now the drag is simply the push from the
air in front of the car making the car
spend more fuel as it goes faster that
is why sports cars are made so sleek so
that they can cut through the air more
efficiently i.e with less drag and well
despite being a literal truck somehow
the tesla semi has a drag coefficient of
0.36 and just so you know that's about
half of a typical diesel truck and
what's more it's even less than a high
performance sports car battery now
that's a lot of power saving going on
but what exactly will hold all of that
power well tesla has a plan for that as
well and by far the biggest contributor
to this plan is their new 4680 cell
built on a new principle that removes a
traditional component of a battery the
battery tabs now normally these would be
the multiple pieces of conductor that
connect a cell to others and this
removes the energy loss through these
tabs giving the battery a promised 10
percent increase in charging times a 16
percent in range and five to six times
increase in power and energy and if that
just sounds way too good to be true the
company is banking on these cells being
confident enough to start production of
a sub 30 000 car in the near future as a
result according to elon the truck has a
300 mile range when fully charged and
another larger version has a 500 mile
range and because tesla plans to make
special superchargers for these trucks
the company claims that it'll take just
30 minutes to juice up to 80 charging
and if you have the larger model that
may mean as much as another 400 miles
and then there are the ways batteries
will be manufactured according to musk
the biggest problem faced by large-scale
ev production is making enough batteries
but tesla as always has a solution the
gigafactory meant to create a bunch of
stuff but by far the biggest product is
batteries the company has gigafactories
in texas fremont and shanghai and all of
them have been being built for quite
some time and if tesla is correct they
are on target to reach 10 gigawatt hours
of production capacity at their 4680
cell pilot plant in fremont this year
and by next year hope to deploy 100
gigawatts of production capacity both in
the berlin and texas factories power
then of course there's what the
batteries power the truck's hearts the
motors with a model 3 motor on each
wheel the small and efficient setup
allows it to pick up speed quickly and
as a result the tesla truck can go to
zero to 60 miles per hour in five
seconds when pulling no load and in case
the load is maxed out around 80 000
pounds the tesla will still beat out
traditional semis being able to hit 60
miles per hour in just 20 seconds safety
finally coming to the end of the list we
have tesla's secret weapon their
security from simple things like sensors
that prevent jackknifing and advanced
navigation which although not new are
never pre-installed in a truck like this
all the way to a whole enhanced
autopilot system that will keep drivers
in a chosen lane and in case someone
veers out it will send out an audible
warning add to that a low center of
gravity from the batteries and the
ability to resist impact thanks to said
reinforced batteries along with impact
resistant glass that is used in the
windshields which just so you know
provide a clearer and more blind spot
free view than any other truck and you
have the insurance companies and truck
driver family's dream the safest truck
in the world and that just leaves one
question what will it cost as we
mentioned there are two versions with
different battery sizes and they both
cost between 150 and 200 000 and
although this is just a little higher
than your standard trucks which can go
from 110 000 to 195 000 factoring in
everything else the things defeat
anything by a strong margin the delays
now i know that tesla promised us a semi
way way back releasing it with the model
3 which has since sold in historic
numbers all the while the semi remains a
prototype but you must understand that
this is not your run-of-the-mill
electric vehicle it is by far the
biggest attempt at making one both in
the size of the machine itself but also
the technologies and factories that are
required to make such things tesla's
recent history if you were to travel
back in time and ask someone about what
tesla is you would get nothing but a
blank stare or mentions of a legendary
serbian scientist however nowadays the
game is entirely in a different
direction as the company has gone from
making a one-off sports car then a small
volume sedan to now a high-end sedan suv
mid-range hatchback and another suv all
with a mini hatchback a truck a van and
yes a set of semis in the works and
although the company's track record when
it comes to new releases hasn't been
perfect with new multiple factories and
entire shipments selling out before
they're even completed it doesn't look
like the company's gonna stop anytime
soon either so with their extensive
research and manufacturing techniques
it's no wonder the company is gearing up
for something as mind-numbing as the
semi and on that note it's time to wrap
up thank you so much for watching and
leave a like if you enjoyed it and with
that i'll see you next time